du fameux rond-point de la Glacière au
port vous ne pouvez pas la manquer la
rue Léon de l'epervenche s'étire
longuement jusqu'au coeur de la ville et
elle longe la place des cheminots est-ce
un indice pour marquer Léon de les
pervengeant les mémoires
qui étaient Léon de le pervenche c'était
un grand navigateur
et politique
Vincent Paul-Marie Jules Simon Léon de
le pervenche est né en 1907 dans une
famille aisée de Saint-Denis pieux et
studio il étudie au lycée Leconte de
Lille où il fréquente de jeunes nantis
comme lui mais les choses se compliquent
à la mort de son père privé de soutien
il renit son camp et manifeste du parti
communiste sous le bras se fait engager
comme journalier à la Compagnie des
chemins de fer et du port de La Réunion
actif militant de la Ligue des droits de
l'homme il rencontre Raymond Vergès
evnor et Simon LUCAS ou encore Jean
hinglot le Front populaire de 1936
encourage les combats pour les Terriens
le 23 août née la Fédération
réunionnaise du travail dont Léon de le
pervenche devient secrétaire général
deux ans plus tard elle fusionne avec la
Fédération des fonctionnaires de la
réunion du docteur Vergès pour former
l'Union départementale réunionnaise des
syndicats et fédérations mais au
lendemain des grèves de 1938 les
pervenches et licenciés la guerre marque
une pause dans les revendications
ouvrières ce qui n'empêche pas Léon de
poursuivre syndicale et d'être
emprisonné sous le régime pétainiste à
partir de 1937 il est élu conseiller
municipal du port est conseillé général
de Saint-Paul il est ensuite merdé port
de 1945 à 1959 et est aussi député de La
Réunion à partir de 1945 jusqu'en 1951
c'est là qu'avec ces homologues
d'outre-mer il inociera la loi du 19
mars 1946 qui fera de la Réunion un
département français la fin de la vie de
Léon est assombrie par des problèmes
privés et internes aux parties il se
retira trois bassins et meurt en
novembre 1961 à l'âge de 54 ans